meine ergebnisse ist tatsächlich man
kriegt da eine neue spielkonsolen
generation also es fühlt sich nicht an
als wäre alles nur ein bisschen schöner
und schneller
sondern man hat wirklich ein neues
spielgefühl warum hauptsächlich deswegen
weil die ladezeiten bei den spielen
wegfallen jeder der das schon mal
gespielt hat kennt dieses problem
man will irgendwohin im spiel und da
muss man erst laden weil das spiel noch
nicht da ist sondern sitzt man da und
wartet und all das gibt es jetzt bei der
neuen playstation nicht mehr wenn die
spiele optimiert sind das wird man
später sehen müssen ob das bei allen
titeln passiert aber erst mal ist das
gefühl so ein spiel spielen zu können
ohne warten zu müssen einfach wirklich
sensationell und jetzt die wichtigste
frage zum schluss wir haben die
spannungen lange aufrechterhalten können
hoffe ich wo bekomme ich denn jetzt noch
eine playstation her obwohl sie schon
überall ausverkauft ist ja erst mal gar
nicht aber wer ein bisschen geduld hat
sony hat versprochen dass es am 19
also zum marktstart in deutschland noch
mal eine vorbesteller runde gibt und da
wird man dann noch mal welche kriegen
können die hat man dann logischerweise
sie nicht am 19
aber die sollen dann noch bis ende
november geliefert werden also mit etwas
glück es weihnachten gerettet ganz
wichtig noch der hinweis es gibt
momentan unglaublich viele shops im
internet wo die playstations teilweise
schon um 300 euro angeboten werden und
wo es heißt wir liefern morgen oder bis
zum wochenende
bitte nicht drauf reinfallen es gibt nur
eine ganz kurze liste von händlern die
überhaupt partner von sony sind und bei
denen das offizielle playstation zu
bestellen gibt alle anderen shops bitte
mit äußerster vorsicht genießen und
wirklich erstmal warten auf den 19
dann hoffen dass man noch eine kriegt
und danach kann man immer noch in den
verzweiflungs modus wechseln
mehr nachrichten und bikinis nur bei
bild schau dir hier das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren